everybody this is the first V log of the
gravity falls V logs uh have not you
seen you try have more a shaggy vet
that's ever showed him with two episodes
so this is anything that new but um uh a
few things won't get out of the way real
fast first but everyone's been telling
us do these he logs do these V logs and
so so much telling is pointing a gun to
her head and threatening our family
member but there was somebody at I think
was that kinetic andhe actually got me
the first DVD here um I just want to say
thanks to her because and I don't member
her name I know she told me her name
whatever but she got me this DVD just
gave it to me as a gift and said just
check it out watch it and at some point
I had some extra time and I just popped
it on those are like my lunch show
because I always watch a show during
lunch and I something about the DVD just
look at that cover I don't know how well
it folk but just that cover alone is
like it would you want to see the show I
mean just Lea the shadows and the the
characters and stuff I mean I've been
burnt by movie posters before but
something about this one just looked
really interesting and uh yeah we pretty
much add the first episode here called
tourists trapped and I gotta say on my
side of the fence people just kept
saying watch it and those other things I
was gonna get around to but then you
called me up and you're just like you
have to see like these two episodes
these two episodes are at weeks at lazy
Dunsey amazing like you wouldn't shut up
about it so I was watching the latest NC
review with you over here and I was like
REO I'm gonna head out and I'm like what
he's like yes he said we gotta see the
gravity falls see the ground it's all
show me you put it on and uh yeah it was
pretty fucking really like the first
couple minutes of it I was like shit
well looks I'm like there's gonna be
something else I gotta watch something
else I'm gonna do is that there's codes
at the end of every episode there's a
lot of mysteries and a lot of puzzles
I've seen these episodes already I
couldn't stop yeah I think so on I
thought we were I could not stop okay
when you get to the end okay we didn't
know we're gonna do V logs and then like
uh we've celeea said okay let's do it
with Disney cember uh so I was already
game to the end of season 1
you see the end of season 1 you'll see
why I couldn't stop you'll just feel
like shit I would be able to stop this
is vengeance for the fact that I got to
see all of avatar first isn't it uh yes
and so now you're a baby so guardians of
the galaxy before me to at the well I
got a free I got like they could just
turned it down so I like the rest of my
wife went to house yes I got to see the
week before everyone else who wouldn't
take that opportunity well there you go
I had a chance to see now you're going
to sitting here having seen all these
episodes knowing all the secret codes
and then pointing to me being like you
know nothing Jon Snow
no no but that is again much like
Adventure Time this is a show where when
you watch it again like oh like I never
noticed that it's one of the things
we're going to talk about here
blaze that there are secret codes and
stuff like that all through and you're
supposed to decode them like if you're
like a die-hard fan you'll find a little
Easter eggs but um through the miracle
of cheating and the internet I found a
video that actually says what every
single saying at the end is you never
studied no I never did I cheated that's
how I got through school um so this one
uh just very simple says welcome to
gravity fall very simple uh but now the
way you decode this cuz then what does
that mean there could mean anything
okay but this no this is really
interesting cuz do you know how to
decode it I did I I thought I just saw
the first episode all I saw was you
paused it for three seconds I mean there
was like a bad scramble hand there at
the end and then but all I know K by not
I almost have you're gonna see some
random letters that seem to be like you
know maybe kind of wheel for J like
maybe the spaces are letters or you know
something like that but what just top
your head would you think of gonna I
quit I mean that's why I maybe it's an
anagram maybe it's mathematical maybe
it's I have no idea I just saw it only
once
okay no here's and get only three
seconds okay cuz again I cheated I
looked online uh but this is really
fascinating so okay at the beginning
credits um they show you a whole bunch
of stuff and when the title pops up you
hear kind of this whisper you know like
this like that it just sounds like
nonsense if you listen closely done
sound like anything apparently if you
play it backwards it says three letters
back huh well that's weird
and then when you go to the VN the jumbo
apparently with every letter you just go
three letters back and that gives you
you know the correct letter and that
spells out the message that's it
Oh bullshit you have to play something
backwards but one normal viewer would go
and play something backwards oh it's
pretty obvious
oh yeah bullsh that's why you couldn't
figure out um but I don't even think I
was paying attention during the opening
credits this is this is the first one I
guess technically it's the third episode
but it wasn't paying attention to the
other two episodes of it this is the
first time I've really seen this so so
but yeah so we will again through
cheating we'll also say what the
messages are at the end cuz some are
just throw away jokes others are like
ooh like that's kind of intriguing um so
what do you think welcome to gravity
falls means uh I think it means this is
going to be a kick-ass show and it's
even better watching it the second time
uh because with this first episode we
talked about this first episode you see
a dipper and Mabel there is sent to
gravity falls for the summer which you
brought a good question like is the
whole show over the summer and I'm like
I think it is just this one mic because
my only thing is you've limited yourself
to 60 episodes then well Rose I will see
what you do yeah cuz second season is
still going and I'm kinda with you I'm
like well we're we gonna go with that
like this is seem a shorter tighter
experience this is like and then that
next summer um or maybe it's like Doctor
Who maybe the summer's regenerate maybe
they keep coming back as different
people oh no the summer is a targets
it's long it's like longer on the inside
oh so so anyway so yeah they're sent to
gravity falls you can't get the idea
really fast they're just they're inside
too much they're playing their games and
stuff so you see these pair hands
they're the parents just throw you know
a summer camp so stuff um and throw them
out there and uh dipper is just there
with his uncle stare grunkle Stan I try
to pay attention why they call grunkle
Stan and ISIL or crunkle cuz I don't
with the G as far as I know okay oh my
god Intellivision Collor krinkle i try
to pay attention why they called him
that
just like I just sounds like they just
say grunkle Stan so I might have missed
it uh but I was trying to listen I
didn't get it uh so he goes and he finds
this b-max on a tree that turns out his
fake is made metal and there's a device
in there he pushes one button just one
of the buttons uh and this door opens up
and there's this there's this book that
has six fingers on the front and a three
on it and it has never meant for the
world in living yeah very uh Book of the
Dead and it has all these little things
written in there and codes and ways
gravity falls works and all these
secrets and at the same time Mabel first
of many is dating a boyfriend that's
weird and strange and it turns out is
known which I also that one of the best
lines was it due to their pale skin and
bad attitudes they're often confused for
teenagers but my favorite again watch it
I wouldn't get this the first time
watching it again when he shows her he
says you know you don't know what you're
dealing with and he opens that the book
and says known since she goes bought he
says oh no no it's all verses I noticed
I just thought it was a joke no no no I
love that he got it right after he said
he actually did get know by accident but
yeah yeah flash to the gnomes
oh sorry this one I just thought it was
a joke cause I'm like oh that's funny
cuz like really gnomes would be
threatening and holy shit turns out they
are and hilarious um so it turns out
they're gnomes they want Mabel to be
their uh gnome Queen they just need to
know Queen which makes you ask what
happened to the first gnome queen with
they have an answer that yet but I'm
really curious Lee took her out I don't
maybe I love to see that like just this
giant like Sir Queenie Lily just have a
pointy hat on her head it's like they
could really do a humping out a little
gnome eggs yeah so um yeah quickly
thought uh so they go ahead and they
outrun the gnomes and they use the leaf
blower to blow him up pretty much and
dipper is now using the book also as
like his own personal diary which I
forgot we should be and Trey if he ever
does find the author uh be like you know
hey where what's all this chipper is
written here
I had the whole last half of this book
written in invisible ink you see asshole
no I can't read shit umm so yeah pretty
much when uh it's just about to end uh
Stan goes downstairs types this message
some sort of code into the vending
machine it opens up and he closes it and
make it very clear that's not like a
joke thing like it's something's going
on and as soon as that played for me I'm
like I'm watching this show like I love
this mix of both really funny adventure
time style comedy uh with this setting
but also this very legit mystery going
on of the secrets and these codes and is
something bigger that you don't
understand it's probably supernatural
and I just know like I have to see it
from this point on so it what are your
thoughts on first episode intro it was
alright yeah Sharon uh III the intro
caught my attention was like I'm sure
you're wondering why the hell I'm
sitting here running away in the Gulf
card from a giant monster with my sister
like you know so it it gave the leave in
it had me um when they were just working
at the mystery shack I just loved that
location and the first up it reminds me
of the Wisconsin Dells that's the first
thank you all I could think of is all
the tourist traps at the Dells um so do
you know I could totally relate to that
and just like my god people spend money
on anything but so it reminded me of
that I think I was telling you I was
like you own this feels like I'm like
this is like an old LucasArts adventure
game come to life like I'm up a little
inventory screen to pop up and I can
take a little cross yeah I am and yeah I
brought you give book to sister Reed but
yeah and like so as much as I love it
there's a part of you it's just like man
I wish I could just play this like not
even watch it but just play it but yeah
it honestly it's the atmosphere the
animations really really good um there's
just details in every corner it's just
really interestingly the backgrounds
yeah yeah the bandar-log backgrounds in
the goofy locations and the sense of
humor that reminds me of like I feel
like that's like cursive it
like secret of monkey island like
crossed with the x-files or lost or
something yeah I think what you know it
may be that to me it's not as much loss
as much as like x-files maybe made s or
what I like um but the fine thing you
know you're talking about the detail a
lot of stuff now now watching it a
second time I'll see certain symbols
it's like oh I know that is what I know
what that is and that's also train my
eye for future episodes to look like you
know well what else could be something
what else I know it's like there's one
episode it could just be a mistake or
something there's like a light bulb or
something that has six fingers you know
it was goofy as goofy as the show is you
can just tell there's a ton of effort
put into it oh God like it's not just
here's a series of jokes like you can
tell it's like know somebody thought
really hard about this and and cuz like
then you show me a couple episodes over
from later in the season the video game
episode I'm just like you could tell
these creators at least to grow up in
the 80s or have 80s awareness cuz it was
like our style of humor yeah like the
Street Fighter jokes and the you know
which will save that for another time
when we do that episode but you know
it's I think we were talked about
because I've seen a number of episodes
of adventure time and I like it
perfectly fine I I think it's really
good for me personally this is more my
style of humor
um it just appeals to me just more on a
basic level I may even respect Adventure
Time more by the time this is over just
this is what I find funny and
rewatchable and so it it's got me really
stuck in that's a yes that's again
someone's seen a lotta sewed so far and
a lot of Adventure Time obviously uh I
have know that Adventure Time is a
better show uh it's got even more
mysteries going I have more characters
the the moral dilemmas and all that
stuff they have to go through our better
than gravity falls even though there's
some decent ones in here the world you
can go anywhere be anything there's
almost no limitations it's unbelievable
and it is just there's more variety more
possibility it is a better show but with
that said so far I do like gravity falls
more for the reasons I you said it just
seems more tailored
towards me it's sorry it's our style
yeah I mean just the the woods the dark
shadows and there's something about
what's this ensign keen are you and a
lot of people be like yeah I think
Citizen Kane is one of the best films
ever made I can only watch it maybe once
every five years because it's just like
some movies you can be like oh they're
really good they're just not watchable
or immensely entertaining though like
and I'm not Emma she's I don't want to
say that about Adventure Time I'm just
saying in comparison this is a little
more entertaining and and watchable for
me personally yeah um which is not a
shot against Adventure Time I'm not
saying it's not entertaining I do find
it entertaining so and it is I mean like
I said I think even even though both
shows are not done yet
comparing the two it seems like
Adventure Time like I said it does have
even more mystery and even more
especially the moral dilemmas and the
lessons they have bencher time teachers
are deeper they are smarter and better
um because gravity falls you'll see our
little run of the middle but yeah I
think that some about the the atmosphere
and the the characters and I think
strangely enough there is something
about it sounds weird but the limitation
that the show has where it's all just in
this one place but what can happen in
this one place with Adventure Time it's
very much any world as possible you can
create any dejoy that's wonderful and
that is please keep it so much any world
but sometimes like for me personally a
show where every episodes I couldn't go
to any world we could do this like
sometimes I'm just like I just like one
location yeah it's really just thought
out and just filled with all this detail
and stuff but even that you know the
animation Adventure Time is obviously
different than this too and as a style
of animation it doesn't appeal to me
personally as much um so but again it's
not bad animation and adventure Toto is
just not my style but yeah it's kind of
like I think guardians of the galaxy is
another good example I know somebody
were just like got a movie sort of dumb
and I'm like yeah but it just appeals to
me like that's my style of Dom that I
like or like when we talk about Roland
Emmerich films I love Stargate don't
like Independence Day much like but
they're both dumb I'm like yeah but
stargates my canadough
oh well but and I think what's so great
what dishes have been doing a lot of
recently that really America as I think
of this I think I reckon Ralph I think
of frozen is that they're getting across
these that they can usually do one thing
really do it they can either do like
either really good morals but then the
comedy is okay a really great comedy but
then the moral is kind of okay you know
they sort Center down so a big hero six
yeah exactly one thing really well and
the other thing else but yeah but with
uh gravity falls and frozen and stuff
like that it seems like they're tackling
two very hard things to do what gravity
falls it seems to be that you have some
legitimately funny clever comedy lots of
character lots of character very
distinct character it's like if I was a
show but also this really gripping
mystery where I say I can't miss an
episode I have to know what's gonna
happen I'm I'm interested in it like
just from what I've seen it's like and
why did the uncle open his vending
machine to a secret room downstairs and
like I'll watch again why is there a a
tree like that opens up like a telephone
pole and then like a book buried in the
ground I'm I'm interested and this is
say a show or a movie I always have to
give credit if it actually makes me gasp
at some point I forget it's one of the
episodes coming up I'll bring it up but
there actually was one the gnomes made
me get when they took it off and it was
the gnomes like I burst out like no no
not like laughing like legitimately like
Oh like that like there's actually you
see I um
oh it's a lot of the episodes coming up
like you know a second or third and I
literally gasped and I said oh my god
this show has me like it has me hogged
uh and I'll bring it up when it comes
off it's gonna be one of the ones coming
up but I think the only God I don't even
know if I should say this cuz I Christ
only knows the hate I'm gonna have
launched upon we have enough hate from
several I don't eg groups this is not a
slam against the voice actor himself oh
I know you know say the wood this is not
the acting is fine I don't get the voice
of dipper yeah I don't get why he's got
this 25 year all
male voice I and it's and it's like I'm
slowly getting used to it since is the
third episode I've technically seen but
it's weird for me I don't get why that
was necessary because the sisters voice
sounds you know it's okay it is yeah I
mean it's an adult but it sounds like a
little kid he doesn't sound like a
little kid to mean I I can't figure out
like why they did that and again it's
not it's he's acted fine
yeah he's he's fine I know exactly what
you're talking yeah it's just they
picked that like an older voice actor
and I'm not sure why cuz every time I
hear it I'm like just doesn't make any
sense to me why there's something weird
about it like but in that sort of not
good weird way but distracting way to me
like and normally by about the middle of
the episode I kind of forget about it
but always when an episode starts I'm
like oh yeah okay it's the actors but I
think it's the son of John Ritter uh I
believe um but now I feel like an ass
what is it with you he's fine he's an
iodine remember I and you know obviously
we respect Dante Basco yeah I think his
voice acting and avatar was amazing and
I thought his voice acting was fine in
Korra but I thought he was miscast
because of the way they designed on it
that character I'm like this this looks
like very old like I'm like the voice is
not matching the way you drew the
character and it's a similar situation
here
you know Bosco's way sound a little
young for a character looked older in
this case we got a young character that
the voice sounds all old so I don't know
I just don't know why they did that but
that the only thing I can think of um it
does grow any like you said wasn't maybe
you say no like man that's distracting
them by the second episode it's growing
on because it's like you're right he's a
good actor and his not everything it's
the pitch yeah it is weird choice but at
the same time it's it's one of those
things where it warmed up to it so much
now it's like you know okay but I'm kind
of with you I don't know why that
additional choice because because you're
right it's a little bit I think it taps
into that sort of thing that bugs me
about certain shows and
I'm not accusing this show of having it
I thought it was gonna like I was
worried when you show me those first
couple episodes because I thought man
this is sliding into that like hipster
Portlandia territory it's like a war in
the Pacific Northwest and it just I
don't know there is it like oh and we
got a younger kid with an older sounding
voice and like fortunately from what
I've seen it doesn't really stray that
far into it but that was my fear when
you first were showing it to me I'm like
oh god this is gonna be like one of
those hipsters yeah the only the only
major like in-your-face hipster stuff to
me is with a Wendy character which will
is that the the older girl yeah which
was going to she was tottering me in the
the other episodes like you you didn't
see much for here but that was the one
I'm just like like Daniel and before
what yeah before we get the major how
can you anybody I don't hate Wendy but
there's I I got some issues definitely
um but there say you know what it is
it's like in stuff that we live through
through the 90s I didn't hate every 90s
kid you know there was some time like
yeah those characters are alright but
you can still sense that it's a
marketing ploy like visions alone like
this is to appeal to that day and like
yeah that's the thing I see they're like
oh millennial hipster demographic is the
same issue in some ways with big heroes
six with the rest of that team yeah
outside of here oh it's just like this
this just feels like it feels like the
chart says yeah no need a you know
that's my issue I'm not saying it's a
terrible carrier I even know her yet I
mean so but then yeah then so those are
my only two little things I've noticed
and then otherwise really solid oh yeah
I can't wait to watch the rest the last
thing I'll say because we this feel
horribly long that's the first episode
um is that I saw the actress who does
the voice of Mabel I wish I'd been that
pretty much her voice it's a little
higher pitch but that is her voice so it
is funny that we were talking about you
know the different voice and how it
doesn't really change much it but hers
doesn't either but it seems to fit a bit
more it seems a little bit more fitting
I find a lot of times that happens more
with female voice actors everyone we saw
voice actress who plays a Cora at
kinetic on and I'm just like wow
this is really Cora like there's no
there's I'm Dante Bosco is the same you
mean him he's like oh that's just Rufio
and I row and like there it's like only
a slight variation it's pretty much the
same so so but this is just a path yeah
it just depends on the mic after you
know Ozzy with uh with the Ritter guy it
could very much just be that they just
hear me it's like yeah no one has better
timing they have nobody has better
delivery
let's just take a ran skate you know
again the acting is fine yeah I know
you're you're coming from like that for
does yeah the first episode you showed
me I was like oh my god I'm gonna have
listened his voice to the whole episode
money end of it I'm like okay like it's
a heck you well it's good and like every
episode I see I forget about it a little
more more so maybe by about Episode five
I mean I won't even be thinking about it
but and I do it one last thing I know I
lied I swear it's the last thing though
uh is that I have to say on this one cuz
it's the first episode though with any I
mean I don't know if you're this way I
don't know but with any show
particularly a kid show you know
something has shown at Disney and stuff
like that there is always this sense
whenever so you gotta watch you gotta
watch it's like I'll watch it but you go
a little bit with your defenses up like
yeah okay win me over win me over and we
shouldn't we should be open to it and
stuff but there's always this sense of
okay my time is valuable I really want
to be spent well you know and you're
sort of not as open today something so
windy nothing really grabs you as well
and breaks through those barriers and
grabs you and pulls you in uh I have
such immense respect we get so many
recommendations from fans and some of
them are really good all the times I've
sat through things people recommend to
me and I have gone oh my gosh you know
and it's just a crapshoot when you have
people come up to you like total
strangers that are just like alright
well should I trust this person that I
don't know I guess I'll give it a try so
it's always like this fifty-fifty so
yeah I do the same thing I I tend to go
in like guns blazing like ready and like
I swear to god this show one minute in I
was just like dropping guys I was like
dropping guns was like love me like this
also might be the first time I've ever
seen animated this yeah I
love it when the gnome did that when
they reveal their nose and they're just
like so we're gnomes and I just have to
give her see that animated oh or no it's
this I think yeah I actually bringing
that up what it was like and he doesn't
blink have you ever noticed he doesn't
blink I swear to God the entire rest of
the episode I was noticing how much the
character he's just like I think if they
not real they're animated so I was like
wait have they been animating these
characters blinking because they've got
big expressive eyes I'm just like like
oh yeah they are and then I couldn't
unsee it the rest of F is that every
time they plankton like blinked again
Disney we have blanks
so that's episode 1 we'll try not to
make the V launch as long as though
something it's the first episode gotta
gotta go on so uh yeah we'll see you in
a peso too